[Music]  let's go for it we've come here to Angel  Falls to claim this huge overhang one of  the biggest in the world  you just feel like you're flying when  you're hanging from the wall  the sound of the waterfall is like a  constant storm  timing angel falls is very dangerous  I wanna keep climbing when I take a leap  yeah of course  where the rock is being more exposed to  the water the rock it's crumbly it's  very sounding so we'll put that one  protection here gonna be really careful  in this you know on the other hand well  where there's no water at all you can  see that rock is completely different  it's extremely hard  when you get to see this landscape from  above right  you can see how the water is a big  destroyer in a way it dissolves the  rocks  the continuous flow of water for  millions of years made this incredible  islands in the sky  [Music]